bonjour à tous je suis secoué la tectech
aujourd'hui je vais vous expliquer le
rôle des ministres mais d'abord il nous
faut comprendre qui détient les pouvoirs
au sein de
l'État quels sont les différents
pouvoirs de l'État et leur répartition
l'État est constitué de tris grands
pouvoirs qui ne sont pas confiés aux
mêmes personnes le pouvoir judiciaire
c'est l'ensemble des tribunaux le
pouvoir législatif c'est celui d'écrire
et de voter des lois le pouvoir exécutif
et celui qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui
il dispose de l'administration et de
l'armée il appartient au gouvernement de
qui est composé le gouvernement le
président de la République les ministres
et leurs collaborateurs ces femmes et
ses hommes désignés par le président sur
une suggestion du Premier ministre
dirige la politique de la nation il y a
différents types de ministres les
ministres d'État ce sont des ministres à
qui est attribué un titre honorifique
contenu de leur personnalité ou de leur
représentativité les ministres ils sont
à la tête d'un ministère dont les
contours varient selon les gouvernements
les secrétaires d'État ils assistent un
ministre dans un domaine précis comment
s'organise-t-il chaque ministre est à la
tête d'un ministère qui englobe
l'ensemble des services de l'État placés
sous sa responsabilité par exemple le
ministère des outres
C administration peuvent être centralisé
à Paris ou décentralisé dans toute la
France le ministre a un cabinet composé
des collaborateurs qui l'aident dans sa
mission le directeur de cabinet organise
le travail le chef de cabinet fait
l'agenda du ministre les conseillers
sont des spécialistes d'un domaine
spécifique comment
trail il réuniss comité
réunion Conseil des ministres par
exemple a lieu à l'Élysée tous les
mercredis selon l'ordre du jour et les
priorités fixées des projets de loi sont
débattus ils seront validés par le
Parlement avant d'être des textes de loi
officiel qui sont les ministres leur
nombre et leur titre varient ainsi si
les ministères du numérique ou du
développement durable sont relativement
récents des constantes reviennent comme
l'éducation ou
il y a donc un ministre pour
l'utreem bien sûr même s'ils font partie
de la France ces territoires ont un
statut et des besoins particuliers notre
ministre étudie ces dossiers quel genre
de dossier ce sont ceux du ministre de
l'intérieur mais adapté à l'organisation
des territoires il coordonne les actions
des ministères qui interviennent en
outreem comme l'éducation la culture ou
le logement il est aussi en charge de la
mobilité et de la continuité
territoriale
les ministres sont donc les acteurs de
la politique nationale ils dirigent le
pays à bientôt dans un nouvel
épisode